did bill cosby deserve on a moral level
to go free
bill cosby on a moral level deserves to
be in jail for the rest of his life
but on a legal level the courts are not
interested in whether
somebody is good or bad the courts are
interested in the process of due process
the big news of the day is that bill
cosby is now free
according to yahoo news and reuters
reaction to bill cosby being freed from
prison on wednesday after pennsylvania's
highest court overturned his sexual
assault conviction
range from outrage to cheers here are
some of those voices time's up
foundation president tina chen said in a
statement
today's devastating decision to overturn
the conviction of a man who caused so
much harm pain and emotional trauma to
so many women
is a travesty and an injustice it
reminds us again of the struggle that
the survivors of his predatory behavior
and actions have endured to make their
voices heard the semblance of justice
these women had and knowing cosby was
convicted
has been completely erased with his
release today
now here is the thing there's a lot of
outrage today
about the release of bill cosby bill
cosby is not released because he's
innocent bill cosby was released because
the way that the prosecutors got him is
called cheating and what they did here
and this is what the highest court in
pennsylvania found is they violated his
due process
and the fact that there is so much
outrage over
the vacation of the vacating of his
conviction demonstrates that people are
just not capable of separating off the
notion of due process
from whether you think the person is
guilty or innocent or not
right whether you think that that
somebody is guilty or innocent is a very
little value in determining whether or
not
the person had due process and it turns
out that in in bill cosby's case
there are some pretty significant
questions about due process
so gabriel mellor has a good piece over
at the washington examiner
explaining all of this because if you
don't understand the process you don't
understand what happened here the way
the media are covering this it makes it
seem like bill cosby walked because he
was
suddenly found innocent and that of
course is not true
according to the washington examiner's
gabriel miller as a lawyer the
conclusion of bill cosby's long-running
assault case is not so much vindication
for cosby as it is a vindication of the
right to due process
more than a decade ago a district
attorney investigating one of the many
sexual assault claims against cosby
determined there was insufficient
evidence to prosecute him and this is a
big problem in sexual assault cases
it's very difficult to substantiate
sexual assault to the point
of conviction because very often it
turns into a he said she said scenario
in which a woman claims that she has
been abused by a man and the man claims
that
it was consensual and that it was just
rough that that sort of thing happens
all the time for prosecutors and so in
this particular case the prosecutor said
we don't have the evidence to get him
but
they also wanted cosby to have to
testify at a civil trial
now the way that this works is that you
are allowed in civil trial
to say i am not going to testify about
something that could get me criminally
convicted
right so if if you are for example being
sued
on the basis of punching somebody in the
face and it's a civil trial not a
criminal trial
you're allowed to say i don't want to
testify about whether i punch that
person in the face because i could be
incriminating myself
and then i could be convicted based on
the testimony i'm about to give
so what the prosecutors in this case did
knowing they couldn't prosecute
caused me successfully is they said to
cosby in this particular case
you know what we're not going to
prosecute you on this stuff if you if
relying on that promise bill cosby then
testifies
because the fifth amendment no longer
applies you can't claim fifth amendment
privilege against self-incrimination
if there is no possibility of criminal
conviction so for example if
you were called upon to testify in court
that you had not gone to the grocery
store yesterday you can't
test it you can't take the fifth taking
the fifth has no relevance in that
context because you could not be
prosecuted
for not going to the grocery store
yesterday right so
what what you do by removing the
possibility of criminal conviction
is you take away somebody's ability to
use the fifth amendment to protect
themselves against self-incrimination
that's basically what the prosecutor in
this case did and cosby relied upon that
promise
according to malor the district
alternative the district attorney
had an alternative to criminal
prosecution in the 2005 case he believed
that cosby's testimony could be
compelled in the accuser's civil suit if
there is no chance such testimony would
run afoul
of cosby's fifth amendment privilege
against self-incrimination so he made a
public announcement that the case
against cosby was closed
cosby's accuser then filed the lawsuit
and caused he was forced by the courts
to give testimony
after all he had been publicly assured
the criminal case was resolved in the
course of that testimony
he confessed to having in the past
provided sedative drugs to women he
wanted to have sex with
years later that testimony would then be
used by a new district attorney who
successfully brought criminal assault
charges against cosby
and the supreme court of pennsylvania
said no you can't do that once you
promise somebody that they're not going
to be criminally indicted on a matter
and then you compel their testimony in a
civil case you can't then go back and
reverse yourself and say oh you know by
the way
so glad you testified in that civil case
about your guilt now we're going to take
that and we're going to convict you
the supreme court of pennsylvania said
we hold that when a prosecutor makes an
unconditional promise of non-prosecution
and when the defendant relies upon that
guarantee to the detriment of his
constitutional right not to testify
the principle of fundamental fairness
that undergirds due process
of law in our criminal justice system
demands the promise be enforced
and so cosby was out of prison uh and
and he was freed the same day
as mallory points out this is good news
for defendants in pennsylvania who can
benefit from the court's broad
pronouncement a defendant is entitled to
relying reasonably on promises of
prosecutor makes including as here an
insurance made
in a public press announcement of note
there didn't have to be an agreement
between the prosecutor
and the defendant the prosecutor just
has to make an assurance to the
defendant that the defendant then relies
upon
to his detriment and as the court
pointed out if you
felt differently if you feel that the
defendant should then say to the
prosecutor i don't trust you
and so i'm not going to listen to you
i'm still going to invoke the fifth
amendment
this is now encouraging people not to
trust prosecutors which is precisely the
opposite of the result you wish to
obtain
okay so the entire world has gone crazy
about this because once again
they have gone to a bad man got out of
jail as opposed to the courts are not
interested
in whether somebody is good or bad the
courts are interested in the process of
due process
and this does run roughshod through our
system right now right now in the united
states there
seems to be and it is the prevailing
notion that
neutral rights can be dispensed with so
long as we don't like you
and so long as we don't like you rights
should not apply to you we see this in
freedom of association we see this in
freedom of speech
we see this in due process if you're
brett kavanaugh and we have decided we
do not like you
then due process concerns are of no
validity and we should not be worried
about them
at all a single accusation without any
supporting evidence should be enough
to get you tossed in terms of
consideration from the supreme court if
you are a person who utters
a a slur and this
really should not be enough to finish
your career
we still say you know freedom freedom of
speech really should not apply to you
freedom of speech shouldn't apply to you
because you said bad things
well again freedom of speech is a broad
individual right
and it does protect you it should
protect you and i'm not just talking
about
legally here in terms of due process you
are talking legally when you're talking
about cosby i'm talking about the
generalized perception that people
deserve a due process
which is both social and legal that
needs to be preserved
especially for people you don't like the
same thing is true a freedom of speech
and so-called cancer culture
right there does have to be a
generalized attitude that you're allowed
to say
what you want to say and that doesn't
mean that people can't react to you
socially
it does mean the notion that free speech
is the danger which has been used as
sort of a club against social media
lately
and social media the left says is bad
because it allows people we don't like
to speak freely and so we should toss
donald trump for example from facebook
and from twitter
that's really dangerous stuff once you
start believing that rights that adhere
to you as an individual and preach this
government
no longer exist because we don't like
what you're saying
now you have entered the realm of
tyranny so
did bill cosby deserve on a moral level
to go free
bill cosby on a moral level deserves to
be in jail for the rest of his life
but on a legal level right and on a due
process level and on a societal level
bill cosby should not be in jail
based on the prosecution of his trial by
the way there are serious questions
about that trial with regard
to allowing some 19 women to testify
against him
on the basis of prior experiences with
him outside the statute of limitations
harvey weinstein is going to make the
same case
so once again due process does have to
you do have to have some neutral laws
of of neutral applicability or we can't
live together as a society it just turns
into pointing figure
fingers and who we decide is worse and
more guilty
that day i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the ben shapiro show if you did go
ahead and hit that subscribe button so
you stay up to date with all our future
content